Mein Name ist Mai.
Ich freue mich, dass ihr alle
hier seid und noch wach seid.
* Applaus *
Viele von euch kennen mich
wahrscheinlich gar nicht.
Das liegt daran, dass ich
zu den Science-Youtubern gehöre.
Und wer interessiert sich schon für
Naturwissenschaften? Richtig?
Hey!
Ich bin Chemikerin.
Das finden viele
eigentlich ganz cool.
Aber manchmal ist es auch doof!
So wie heute zum Beispiel.
Mai, sagten sie, wir machen dieses
megafette YouTube-Event am Wahlabend,
geile Liveshow, wir haben
viele große YouTuber am Start.
Vielleicht kannst du
als Wissenschaftlerin
ja was zu Umweltschutz
und Klimawandel sagen.
Ja klar, dachte ich, Superthema.
Klimawandel, da kommt Stimmung auf!
Das Publikum wird toben!
Ich bereite am Besten schon mal
einen Stagedive vor.
Also keine Sorge,
wir werden etwas über Umwelt reden.
Aber damit ihr euch nicht langweilt,
werde ich euch mitnehmen
auf einen kleinen Psychotrip.
Ich habe nämlich als Chemikerin
natürlich ein bisschen
selbstgemachtes Crystal Meth dabei.
Nein, Quatsch!
Wir sind hier bei Funk. Crystal Meth
gibt's, wenn die Kameras aus sind.
Mit Psychotrip meinte ich eigentlich,
wir machen einen kleinen Ausflug
in die Psychologie.
Das ist eine ziemlich
faszinierende Wissenschaft.
Die Psychologie weist immer wieder
wissenschaftlich nach,
dass wir Menschen
einfach saudumm sind.
Wobei man das ja auch feststellt,
wenn man mal ein paar
YouTube-Kommentare liest.
In der Kommentarspalte macht sich
v.a. ein Effekt bemerkbar:
der "Dunning-Kruger-Effekt".
Schon mal was davon gehört?
Der Danning-Kruger-Effekt beschreibt
die verzerrte Wahrnehmung
bei inkompetenten Menschen, die
ihre eigene Kompetenz überschätzen.
Kurz gesagt,
wenn Leute einfach zu dumm sind,
um zu merken, dass sie dumm sind.
Z.B. Donald Trump.
Donald Trump schockiert die Welt
tagtäglich mit seinem Rassismus,
Sexismus und vielem mehr.
Aber was mich mit Abstand
am meisten schockiert,
ist seine atemberaubende Inkompetenz.
Der Mann ist einfach so ...
unintelligent,
dass es eigentlich kein Wunder ist,
dass er mit Wissenschaft
nicht viel anfangen kann.
Deswegen will er auch die USA aus
dem Pariser Klimaabkommen raushaben.
Die ganze restliche Welt
ist sich einig,
dass wir CO2 reduzieren müssen.
Selbst der Papst, also das Oberhaupt
der katholischen Kirche,
ruft alle Menschen dazu auf,
gemeinsam gegen den
Klimawandel anzugehen.
D.h., wir leben in einer Zeit,
in der Wissenschaftler
die katholische Kirche
leichter überzeugen können
als den Präsidenten der USA.
Wobei, ob Donald Trump alles,
was er so sagt, auch meint,
das können wir nicht wissen.
Denn der Mann
ist der größte Heuchler.
Aber das sind wir alle.
Menschen sind Heuchler.
Wir haben gerade das Video gesehen,
die Welt ist voll von Doppelmoral.
Und psychologisch gesehen
ist Heuchlerrei ähnlich
zum Dunning-Kruger-Effekt:
Wir haben hier einen Widerspruch
zwischen dem, wie ich mich sehe,
und wie ich meine Mitmenschen sehe.
Als Heuchler setze ich meinen Mit-
menschen viel höhere Standards auf,
als ich selber erfüllen kann.
Beispiel: ein Politiker setzt sich
öffentlich für Umweltschutz ein,
fliegt selbst aber
mit seinem Privatjet hin und her.
Heuchler.
Oder eine Instagrammerin
ist überzeugte Veganerin,
liebt aber Lederschuhe.
Heuchlerin.
Es ist ziemlich einfach,
andere dafür zu verurteilen.
Aber ganz ehrlich:
Entsprechen eure Handlungen
auch euren Überzeugungen? Immer?
Ich setze mich z.B. dafür ein, dass
Frauen nicht nur für ihr Aussehen,
sondern auch für ihr Gehirn
respektiert werden.
Trotzdem stehe ich jetzt gerade hier,
vor euch, mit aufgeklebten Wimpern.
Tja!
Und Heuchler ist das Schlimmste,
was man so sein kann. Finden wir!
Das haben Psychologen herausgefunden.
Und sie sind total fasziniert davon.
Ich will mit euch eine dieser
psychologischen Studien nachstellen.
Okay?
Ich stelle euch jetzt
verschiedene Fälle vor.
Ihr könnt einmal überlegen, welcher
dieser Fälle am schlimmsten ist.
Fall A: Der hier vorn der ersten
Reihe, der gerade am Handy spielt ...
Kevin, du heißt jetzt Kevin ...
Kevin hat Plastikmüll
in den Wald geschmissen.
Und als man ihn danach fragt,
sagt er:
Nö, hab ich nicht gemacht.
Fall A.
Fall B, da haben wir hier Klaus ...
Du heißt doch bestimmt Klaus, oder?
Klaus hat auch Plastikmüll
in den Wald geschmissen.
Dabei verkündet Klaus
regelmäßig und öffentlich,
Umweltschutz sei das Allerwichtigste.
Was findet ihr jetzt schlimmer?
Kevin, den Lügner,
oder Klaus, den Heuchler?
Die Mehrheit der Menschen
findet Fall B schlimmer als Fall A.
Wir hassen Heuchler.
Wir verachten Heuchler
mehr als Lügner.
Aber wenn man
ganz rational darüber nachdenkt,
ist Heuchelei völlig irrelevant.
Warum? Wir regen uns nicht deswegen
so sehr über Heuchler auf,
weil sie unmoralisch handeln.
Ich rege mich nicht über Klaus auf,
weil er Plastikmüll
in den Wald geschmissen hat.
Ich rege mich nicht dermaßen auf
für den Wald oder die Umwelt.
Ich rege mich v.a. darüber auf,
dass dieser Pisser sich besser
darstellt als er eigentlich ist.
Klaus!
Oder?
Aber während ich mich hier
lang und breit darüber aufrege,
liegt der Plastikmüll im Wald
und niemanden interessiert es.
Und dass der Plastikmüll
wirklich niemanden interessiert,
sehen wir an Fall C.
Fall C, da haben wir hier ... Jerome.
Jerome hat auch Plastikmüll
in den Wald geschmissen.
Und als man Jerome fragt, sagt er:
Ja, habe ich gemacht!
Ich stehe dazu,
ich hab's nicht so mit der Umwelt.
Und wie finden wir Jerome?
Ganz okay, oder?
Wenigstens ist er ehrlich.
Ja, natürlich ist Jerome ehrlich
aber das ist im Wald doch scheißegal,
ob Jerome ehrlich ist oder nicht.
Fakt ist, da liegt Müll.
Weil wir immer nur
an uns selbst denken,
finden wir den Heuchler am
schlimmsten, dann kommt der Lügner.
Und dann kommt
der ehrliche Übeltäter.
Aber wenn wir wirklich
an den Wald denken würden,
dann müssten wir es
genau andersherum sehen.
Wir würden sagen, Klaus,
es nervt, dass du ein Heuchler bist,
aber wenigstens macht sich Klaus
prinzipiell für Umweltschutz laut.
Und Kevin, es ist zwar uncool,
dass du lügst,
aber wenigstens
scheint Kevin zu wissen,
dass er was falsch gemacht hat.
Sonst würde er ja nicht lügen.
Und Jerome hier, der einfach ehrlich
zugibt, auf den Wald zu scheißen,
zu dir müssten wir eigentlich sagen:
Fuck you, Jerome!
(Stimme aus dem Raum:
Fuck you, Jerome!)
* Lachen *
Meiner Meinung nach sollten wir uns
über zwei Dinge einig sein, okay?
Erstens: Umweltschutz ist wichtig!
Wir haben nur eine Erde!
Und versteht mich nicht falsch,
wir brauchen Umweltschutz nicht
für unsere arme Mutter Erde.
Die Erde ist 4,5 Mrd. Jahre alt.
Die Erde wird den Klimawandel
schon überleben.
Wir sind diejenigen, die den
Klimawandel nicht überleben werden!
In der Geschichte der Erde
ist die Menschheit nichts.
Wenn alles schief läuft,
werden wir nichts anderes sein
als ein kurzer Parasitenbefall.
Oder eine kurze Grippe,
von der sich die Erde erholen wird -
in 'n paar Millionen Jahren.
Die Dinos z.b. haben viel länger
auf der Erde gelebt als wir.
Und wo ist T.Rex heute?
Im Hühnerstall.
Also das Huhn ist der nächste
genetische Verwandte zum T.Rex.
Alles, was vom T.Rex übrig ist,
ist ein Huhn.
Ein Huhn, Jerome!
- Was wird von uns übrig sein?
Eben, genau:
Was wird von uns übrig sein?
Auch nicht viel, wenn wir
so weitermachen wie bisher.
Deswegen: wir brauchen Umweltschutz
nicht für unseren Planeten.
Sondern wir brauchen Umweltschutz
v.a. für uns!
Also erstens:
Umweltschutz ist wichtig.
Zweitens: nachhaltig handeln
ist halt sauschwer.
Ein Beweis dafür
ist unsere ganze Heuchelei.
Wenn ich jetzt im Herzen
für Fairtrade bin,
aber trotzdem meine Jeans
bei Primark kaufe,
weil's halt so scheißbillig ist, dann
sagt mir das v.a. eins, nämlich:
Das Richtige zu tun
ist einfach nicht leicht.
Weil uns die Disziplin fehlt, die
Motivation, weil wir Egoisten sind,
weil wir dumm sind.
Aber genau deswegen sind Sachen wie
das Pariser Klimaabkommen wichtig,
damit wir uns gemeinsam gegenseitig
zu konkretem Fortschritt zwingen!
Und ich will hier jetzt nicht
Heuchler in Schutz nehmen,
versteh das nicht falsch, Klaus,
aber ich will nur sagen,
wir sind alle irgendwie Heuchler.
Lasst uns doch wenigstens keine
kleinlichen Motherfucker sein,
die sich gegenseitig beschuldigen.
Sondern lasst uns gemeinsam
unser Bestes geben
und uns gegenseitig dabei helfen.
Danke!
* Applaus *
Und jetzt umarmt euch alle!
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2017)